leading in from the last video we know
that the black tusks have invaded the
Pentagon with two goals in mind firstly
to loot everything they deem useful in
their mission and secondly to extract
the newly developed perfusion bioreactor
the device that could lead to the cure
of the Dahl flu but we didn't have to
meet you particularly far into these
missions to notice a few familiar pieces
scattered around the labs not only who
we found that DARPA has been the brains
behind a number of items in the shd tech
arsenal but they also seem to have been
responsible in one way or another for
the high-tech gear used by the black
tusk
[Music]
[Music]
you
last 60 years the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency otherwise known
as DARPA has held one mission to make
pivotal investments and breakthrough
technologies for national security
DARPA dates back to 1957 the time when
the Soviet Union launched the Sputnik 1
satellite into an elliptical low-earth
orbit as a side note for those
interested the satellite and its
unintended success triggered the
beginning of the space race and a new
era of political military technological
and scientific developments it was at
this time that a commitment by the
United States was made so that from this
time forward they were to become the
initiator and not the victim of
strategic technological surprises the
results over the years have included
game-changing military capabilities and
precision weapons and stealth technology
but also icons from modern society such
as the Internet automated voice
recognition and language translation in
the lore of the division it stated there
is a research and development department
of the strategic homeland division this
R&D department is responsible for all of
the high-level development of
proprietary shd technology or shape tech
as it's more commonly known by this is
the shd group that maintains the
agency's arsenal of weapons field
equipment and custom tech ops gear I
quote to retain its covert status and
avoid intrusive political oversight
division Rd operates out of a consortium
of dummy companies the law goes on to
tell us of how the status of a division
agent is considered a state secret
classified at the very highest level the
identity of the agents are only
available to the most senior members of
the executive branch in the Pentagon in
fact all division personnel
specifications and operational matters
are classified as top secret to all
Outsiders including high-ranking
government officials at no time does it
discuss the possibility of shd R&D team
working alongside DARPA in order to
produce this state-of-the-art weapons
and technology but in saying that it
wouldn't be hard to imagine how this
could have happened
DARPA is the national agency with a
mission to create the latest and
greatest in advanced technology with a
particular focus on military the shd is
a highly classified last line of defense
that requires agents to be able to work
autonomously
without the support of an upper
leadership structure agents are required
to have the best in training and
equipment as their activation is likely
to be at a time where the odds are
stacked heavily against them this is
only a small thing but I find it odd
that DARPA isn't really mentioned in the
structure of the sh t either in the game
or the supporting books and information
more that the R&D team in the division
was sort of a darker in their own right
somewhat separate from the Pentagon and
the Department of Defense DARPA is a
part of the Department of Defense and is
highly influenced by political agenda
this seems a little contradictory
against a lot of the other information
regarding the supposedly isolated branch
of the strategic homeland division okay
so how about we ignore that for a minute
let's just say the DARPA directly
involved with the development of the sh
d tech that we all know and love or at
the very least have some sort of
collaboration going on with the sh d R&D
team the still doesn't explain why we're
also seeing a large number of black tusk
technologies being developed in the labs
it's possible that what we're seeing in
the DARPA labs are just prototype
versions of the sh d tech that the
division users are more finalized to
finish version of the product thanks to
the R&D team but if this is the case why
don't the division have access to the
war Doc's or the other robotics that
we're seeing the black tusk using and
why do the black tusk have access to any
of this at all we'll get into that soon
I think it's likely that the division
did in fact have access to the larger
robotics drones and war dogs and their
R&D team could have been involved with
the development of them alongside DARPA
in fact if you look at some of the plans
on the walls it shows them being listed
as this HD tech but when you think about
the role of a division agent and how
they spend the majority of their service
blending in with society going about
their normal lives a giant metal robot
dog or a drone the size of a bus isn't
the most practical tool to keep hidden
away also if you think about their role
after activation they're there to keep
society together and the somewhat
terrifying looking robot hounds etc
probably isn't the easiest way of
earning the trust of the civilians
around you we've all seen way too many
movies where the robots end up being the
bad guys there ain't no way on trusting
a robot dog with a 50 Cal strapped to
his back
[Music]
okay so we've established that Darfur is
somewhere involved with the development
of EHD tech including the prototyping of
technology when we were first introduced
to the black tusk they were described as
a large private military contractor with
ties to the US government shortly after
the outbreak hit New York the black
tusks were hired by an unknown
organization to pave the way for a new
dynasty
this included orders to dismantle and
eliminate any functioning order of the
US government including the strategic
homeland division by now I feel it's
pretty safe to say that this unknown
benefactor or organization has close
ties to the government and this isn't
really a huge surprise as the government
has been using PMC's for many years the
more interesting part is how they've
been given the state-of-the-art
technology developed by DARPA long
before the US military were able to get
their hands on it
so these ties in the government must be
from the very highest level the Speaker
of the House vice president and even the
President himself wouldn't have been
able to slip a couple of war hounds into
his fanny pack while he was off out on a
Sunday bike ride and then drop them off
at the local black tusk reception at
least not without being noticed we're
talking about Darfur in the Pentagon
here I like to imagine these would
probably be among the most secure
buildings on the planet but this isn't
the case anyway we know for a fact that
the black tusks were responsible for at
least one of the two deaths of the three
top people in the government at that
time with the other death seeming just a
little bit too suspicious and finally
the third the Speaker of the House being
turned to this side to be used as a
puppet for future plans
maybe it's someone on the inside someone
able to sneak some plans out and the
black tusks were able to recreate this
in their own labs this was likely to be
long before the outbreak first hit New
York but sneaking some plans up doesn't
sound like a particularly easy job
either I'm no security expert but I'm
pretty sure there are all sorts of
measures in place to make sure things
aren't leaked out to the wrong people no
I think this is much bigger than that
this person or organization has
influence and control within the
government far greater than those who
are supposed to be running the country
they also seem to have extensive
resources to be able to fund a PMC as
large as the black tusk to have them
essentially be the muscle behind the
goals of a new world order these people
have been controlling the world for a
long time in the shadows there's no
telling how far back this goes that
could have been manipulating the way
that the US and even the world has been
running for a long time except now for
some reason they've decided to pursue a
more direct line of control the black
tusks are just the front facing side of
a much bigger enemy we know that the
black tusks were first employed around
the time of the outbreak but this
organization has been working on this
for far longer I feel comfortable in
predicting that this organization was
directly involved with the outbreak that
dr. Gordon Amherst was just a front to
keep them hidden for a little bit longer
he was just supported and manipulated
and carrying out this awful deed that
will [ __ ] the u.s. taking out the
government and leaving it wide open for
attack from the only ones on the planet
who were actually prepared for the
dollar flu outbreak it was a
conversation between many and Kelso that
really shed light on this unknown
organizations plans even if they were
only speculating at the time you have a
lot of assets
BC and a quick efficient symbolic
victory here would help them sell
themselves as liberators we care about
that I think their plan depends on them
looking like the good guys why else
would they hook up with Ellis he gives
them legitimacy which means fewer people
fighting against them and more people
fighting alongside them against the bad
guys meaning us meaning anyone that gets
in their way but especially this whole
thing from the very start was never
meant to be seen as a full hostile
invasion and takeover of the country
they were hoping to be seen as the
heroes the saviors of the nation while
the country was in its darkest hours it
was them that would help us make it
through to the other side maybe it was
an attempt to show how weak the current
system is and that major change is
required they've been making it the goal
to show that the true enemy is the
government and everyone who supports
them they've worked the Speaker of the
House into a position of being sworn in
as president after talking him into
joining this side he has been told that
he is a part to play later on this could
be to help sway public opinion or
perhaps they were wanted to make an
example of him showing how easy the old
government failed due to the in-house
corruption the sheer planning and
patience on their part to get to this
point is impressive horrendously
oversimplifying it the plan seems to
have been the following step one hire a
large private military company equipping
them with the latest weapons and
technology and preparing them for the
outbreak ahead of time step 2
[ __ ] the country by a biological
attack step 3
find a puppet in the White House and put
them at the head of the government step
4 eliminate any remaining government
resistance that have survived the
biological attack this includes the
strategic homeland division step 5 click
the broad-spectrum antivirals and the
perfusion bioreactor
step 6 save the country by offering the
cure-all for everything viral and talk
about how terrible the previous
government was and steps of world
domination I'm not totally convinced by
step 6 I think there's a little more
reason behind why they want the Cure so
bad and I haven't really fully wrapped
my head around that one yet
regardless at the stage they haven't
managed to complete step 5 year and at
both times it was the remaining division
agents that were able to stop them to
the black tusk and their employers the
division were originally seen as a minor
nuisance to be dealt with but over time
regardless of how many agents have been
killed they've been proven otherwise now
is the time to put an end to their
efforts I stated this in the last video
on the Pentagon but I believe the next
logical step to the black tusk is an
operation focused on reclaiming the
antivirals in the bioreactor and putting
the final nail to the side of the
strategic homeland division and this is
where episode 3 comes in all we have
officially been told at this stage is
that the division is on the hunt for
Aaron keener and that is back in New
York but what I think is actually
happening as the division are aware of
what the black tusk is planning and on
the lookout for kina is the solution for
a couple of the problems that are
currently being faced I stated in the
last video that we might be seeing a
familiar face dr. Jessica candle is an
expert in the field to run the
bioreactor and the mass production of
the antiviral but maybe for some reason
she can't do it or isn't available so
the next best thing could be dr. Fatali
Chernenko who is currently with Erin
keener so this is one reason the
division could be hunting him down the
other reason maybe the division isn't
ready to abandon the white house this
isn't just the base of operations for
the JTF in the SH D in Washington this
is a monument of how things were in the
United States before the outbreak and
the attack perhaps they see this as more
than just the abandonment of the current
base of operations and that the symbolic
meaning behind holding control of such a
building was important enough to fight
for maybe just maybe the division are
looking for Erin kina for help
protecting the last government control
building in the United States Capitol
those of you familiar with my videos and
in my discord will be used to make crazy
ideas around Erin keener although I
agree he's done some pretty horrible
things since he was first activated
I believe he's become aware of the
corruption in the government long before
we were
kina has been in a position where he's
had to fight against former colleagues
in order to do what he feels is right
for the people of the United States
up until recently everyone would the
government is against him and a
potential threat so he's had to play
very defensively and make sure it's
always a few steps ahead of us we don't
know how many agents he has under his
command but we can see the difference
just one or two agents can make maybe
the division is seeking out kena for
assistance the division of very quickly
becoming the outcasts in Washington not
the Bechet crazy revenge driven outcasts
but a force that is outnumbered and
slowly losing control of the capital the
black tusk and their employers are doing
their best to make the division look
like the bad guys and over time public
opinion will change to support those in
control those who are providing more in
the way of help towards rebuilding of
society the division only have a few
options left right now they hold the
tools to success with the antivirals and
bioreactor but there is no way they can
hold up against the superior numbers in
advanced technology of the black tusk
they need to pull all the numbers
together that they can and Keena could
be the key we might even be seeing some
of those missing agents from the first
wave that are covered before probably a
year ago now I'm not saying that will
necessarily be fighting alongside kina
but that he might hold the answer to
what we need to push back the black tusk
keener himself really is a much looser
threat to what the division are
currently facing he hasn't really done
anything over the last few months that
were aware of why else would he risk the
defense of the white house at this time
by traveling to Coney Island in New York
this video has basically been a huge ng
and brain explosion of speculation on
the current and future events of the
black tusk and division I've handed my
thoughts around some of these theories
in a number of videos but I'll be the
first to admit that there are many
different directions the story could
take some of this is based on
information that could be found in game
and some is purely speculation with a
little bit of hope of how I'd like to
see the story go this script was pretty
much written straight from my mind in a
single hit I'd usually have my editor
and manager to read over this to help me
make sense and to stop me from going too
crazy but she's been a little
preoccupied with the running of the
household during the super busy week I
would have approached my executive
producer for help but there's no
reasoning with him he's just a slave
driver hopefully you were able to follow
this okay
tinfoil hat Joe is a mind of his own and
sometimes the train of thought can be a
little hard to control
before I go must think a number of you
have shown your support for my new
twitch channel as I said before thus why
be eating into my limited video creation
time it's more of an extra if you wanted
to get to know me a little better or
show some support etc truth be told I'm
a terrible streamer to distract with
chat to play games properly get too
distracted with the game to offer any
sort of decent banter yet oddly enough
I'm finding it a hell of a lot of fun
thanks a game to the number of you who
have thrown bits donations and subs my
way I don't have a schedule or anything
so it's super kind of you considering
how infrequently it could be doing this
the response has fully blow me away
anyway I hope you've enjoyed this video
and I'll catch you soon in the next one
Cheers
you